you can't make a film like this and blow
you've got to keep total control that's
one thing that those of you who work in
the industry I'm sure you know and
understand you you can't be out of
control out of your mind it took 10
months to film this picture because none
of the effects had ever been done before
there was nothing to lean on the way
they used to do show breath in the old
days when they made films like Lost
Horizon out here they would film these
pictures in the Glendale Ice House which
doesn't exist anymore where they made
great big blocks of ice they would build
sets in the Glendale ice house and it
was freezing cold and you could see
breath when we went to do the Exorcist
there was no way there was no Glendale
ice house we had to make that cold and
as I say once we got to that sequence
the lights would go on the movie lights
and the temperature would rise we have
to shut down turn the air conditioning
back up and wait until it got above
freezing so it took a very long time to
do this you had all of the effects being
done with a 13 year old girl and so they
couldn't be raced along they couldn't be
shoved into a schedule there was no
schedule I had no idea how long it was
going to take but Ellen told me last
night there was one scene that kept
showing up on the schedule four or five
times what was that no it's more than
that this scene where I run to a room
and she's bouncing around on the bed we
shot it he didn't like it so he put it
on the schedule again and it was if time
allows so it's on the schedule every day
if time allows and then every once in a
while time would
when we would shoot it and then he
didn't like it and then it would go back
on the schedule if time allowed so it
was on four months the same scene and
time allowed five times and on the fifth
time he was happy with it I like it now
Ellen I think it's really terrific yeah